[Music]
foreign
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
Sonia soda the chief leader writer at
The Observer and Henry Hill the deputy
editor of conservative home they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight we'll speak to them very
shortly but first let's have a look at
what's on some of those front pages
the guardian leads with the attack in
Nottingham in which three people were
killed
the Metro also leading on the attack
calling it a white van knife horror
the attacks in Nottingham Nottingham
also on the front of the Daily Mail
the Stars headline Killers Rampage
and the sun also caused the attack a
rampage
the Ft leads with the governor of the
bank of England's words that inflation
is taking a lot longer than hoped to
come down
while the I says mortgage level stress
is to hit levels last seen in the 1980s
reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you're watching
us
and we're joined tonight by Sonia soda
and Henry Hill so let's get started
shall we very good evening to you both
thanks so much
uh for joining us
um a very somber uh press preview
looking ahead to tomorrow's front pages
the majority of them leading on the
horrific scenes in Nottingham today
Sonia your take on all of this to start
with
uh yes so absolutely terrible scenes
unfolded in Nottingham today
um there's still a lot that's unclear
about what happened overnight but what
we do know is that two students both age
19 uh were stabbed to death
um by a 30 well there's a 31 year old um
suspect involved and a man in his 50s
was also killed and police suspect that
he was the owner of the white van
um that the suspected killer used to
drive around after
um
as well as the deaths of the two 19 year
olds uh the van was driven again the
police think it was the same suspect
um uh into some people
um they are okay I think I think it was
two people so there's still a lot that
we simply don't know yet we know that
this was a 31 year old suspect there's
absolutely no information yeah about
what is potential motivations might be
we know that the counter-terrorism
police have been involved but the police
say that that is normal with an incident
of this scale where they're making so
many um inquiries
um it's obviously absolutely devastating
for the families of the two students
who've lost their lives and their
friends uh their friends in in
Nottingham and for the whole student
community in Nottingham but I think
there's a lot that we still don't know
here yet yeah absolutely and Henry you
know
there's no words to describe really how
terrible this is to teenagers on their
way home from a night out and then you
know stabbed to death but of course the
big question hanging over people in
Nottingham is why
yes it is and we simply don't know you
know this is an ongoing and active
police investigation uh this the the
suspect was only taken into custody
today and there is a natural tendency to
fill that kind of void with speculation
but I think it's it's important that you
know we will know we will find out the
police will release the information in
due time and we will have those answers
for the moment I think it's important
one you know that we make sure that you
know as the police will surely be doing
that there are no further attacks and
that everybody is safe and then it is
important that we take the time to wait
for the facts to emerge that we don't
rush to any conclusions or judgments and
that can be difficult when we don't
where we have that void of information
because we naturally want to talk about
something of this magnitude and we need
to fill that space with something but
nothing good ever comes of doing that so
we will find out in due time but for the
moment we simply don't know why this
happened yeah absolutely police say they
are keeping an open mind when it comes
to the motive and so yeah I mean there's
not a huge a huge amount of variety in
terms of what's on the front pages
tomorrow but we're just going to mention
the front page of the sun now
um which has the photographs of the two
teenagers who who they say were killed
in Nottingham
um and as you said it was you know two
19 year olds on the way home from a
night out at 4am
um so it's a total tragedy and as you
would expect this is a major national
incident it's been dominating news
coverage all day so you really would
expect it to be on on the vast majority
of front pages
um which it is
yeah absolutely every parent's worst
nightmare let's move on to the financial
times Henry of course one of the other
big stories today is the covert inquiry
which kicked off
yeah absolutely so this is Dame Heather
highlights inquiry which you know may be
familiar to viewers from the row between
it and the cabinet office about the
release of Boris Johnson's texts which
due to the pace of events already feels
like it took place months ago but in
fact I my my diary reminds me was in
fact relatively recent and this is the
comprehensive investigation into what
went wrong with the or indeed Right In
fairness with the government's covered
response it wants to investigate what
lessons we can learn whether the United
Kingdom was prepared and what uh good or
bad steps were taken during that process
now it's going to take its mooted to
take three years to complete we don't I
don't think we're certain that it will
take that long some of these judge-led
inquiries have taken an awful lot longer
to get to the truth uh so I think there
is a tension there and this is one of
the problems with the way that we run
public inquiries in this country is that
there is a tension between two of the
objectives of the inquiry the first is
we want to find out what happened with
the with the covid response as quickly
as possible so we can learn lessons and
the other is that we want to get really
down into the guts of it so that we and
find out who made bad decisions assign
blame give some catharsis and closure to
those who were affected by the pandemic
and lost loved ones now the first of
those objectives would be better served
by a much faster inquiry a sort of an
inquisitorial
inquiry that maybe took evidence on a
no-blame basis on a black box basis that
wasn't published and that could get to
the lessons really quickly so we could
apply them and then this other process
could be conducted separately and it
could take more time to go into those
granular details but at present we're
lumping both of those together into one
and so it we are going to take longer to
get to some of those answers about
pandemic preparedness and I think it
would probably be ideal
yeah and Sonya it was really interesting
wasn't it the the league Council of the
inquiry had some very interesting
comments to make uh on this today in the
inquiry opening in terms of the lack of
preparedness for a covid
um pandemic and and the fact that the
country was distracted by dealing with
brexit
yeah so this is the Barrister advices
the um inquiry and I think we're going
to be hearing a mix of things that sound
quite familiar to us as the inquiry goes
on and stuff um that is new but this is
the first day and the first stage of the
inquiry will be looking at preparedness
and there's already been a lot of
discussion about preparedness
um there's been Revelations about X
exercises that took place in Whitehall
for example in preparation for a flu
pandemic where recommendations and
findings were not acted upon
um so I but I think there's going to be
more that emerges
um through the course of the inquiry and
it's obviously been um you know in the
news in recent days and weeks because
there is this legal battle between the
government and between the inquiry
itself in terms of what material the
government has to hand over and what
whether it's the government who gets to
decide what's relevant or whether it's a
judge into in charge who gets to decide
what's in the public interest and what
should be released to the public
um you know so so that that those legal
wrangles May yet delay things more
um I agree with I mean I think it's very
important that there is this statutory
inquiry that's led by a judge where she
does have the power to summon Witnesses
where she does have the power to demand
documents I think that's in incredibly
important but I also think that actually
we could have probably done the sort of
more rapid review that Harry's talks
about to be honest I think we could have
done that by now and indeed a country
like Sweden has already published um
their report I've looked at some of the
findings from that for example and so I
think you know optimally we would have
got the got the sort of Rapid review uh
with lessons for what we need to do
differently if you know if this won't
happen of course but if another pandemic
were to sort of drop on our door in the
next couple of years
um you know to have those lessons ready
and waiting but I do think that the
statutory nature of this inquiry is
really really important and you do need
that thoroughness as well and Henry of
course at the center of this inquiry are
the bereaved families but there is also
a side show in terms of Boris Johnson
and his dispute with the cabinet office
over you know releasing material to the
inquiry
yeah absolutely so this is an ongoing
dispute basically the uh Dame Dame
Heather Hallett the judge leading the
inquiry has requested that all of Boris
Johnson's WhatsApp messages with 40 key
members of the government be handed over
to the inquiry so that they can be
reviewed at anything relevant can be
included in the inquiries remit now the
dispute from the cabinet office is the
cabinet office is wanting to hand over
redacted versions because they say Well
they're happy to hand over anything
relevant uh the WhatsApp exchanges
contain all sorts of information which
might not just be irrelevant but might
also be personal uh and therefore to be
improper to hand that over now I believe
the cabinet office is going to take that
to court it will be very interesting to
see whether or not they win I think that
you know so James e d a very senior
lawyer who works for the government
argues that it's essential for
protecting the principle of uh uh free
cabinet debate and private cabinet
debate he's a better lawyer than me but
I don't know whether that's going to
hold water but it really highlights I
think the tension between the fact that
all of the law covering this stuff is
old right the the inquiries that dates
back 2005 the public records act are
much older than that the Freedom of
Information Act dates back to I think
2001 and all of that predates WhatsApp
and it predates the age when politicians
advisors and officials would have had
something like what where they were
simultaneously conducting official
business personal business private
business and all the rest of it so I
suspect that the cabinet's office will
end up having to hand over everything
it's sort of Dame Heather's threatening
to publish it all she and her team
simply wish to go through it I think
that's going to be a very high argument
to resist but it does highlight the fact
that we need to bring the law governing
public records and public information up
to date so that we don't have this kind
of dispute in future and it's clear what
the status of WhatsApp messages and so
on are when a judge comes knocking at
the door yeah certainly it seems very
unclear as things stand Henry uh Sonia
will give you a little break more to
discuss coming up more of our papers
more of our pay-per-view including
coverage a former president Donald
Trump's court case in Miami as seen here
in the guardian we'll be talking about
that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me now Sonia Soto the chief
leader writer at The Observer and Henry
Hill the deputy editor of conservative
home uh and Sonia to first uh front page
of your paper and like many also
covering um Donald Trump's historic uh
court appearance extraordinary uh
obviously he's pleaded not guilty to all
of these charges but even if convicted
it it won't necessarily stop him from
returning to the White House
no and that's just kind of quite a crazy
thing to say isn't it so it's huge story
Donald Trump is facing 37 charges of
concealing classified documents from
federal officials he appeared in a Miami
courtroom today
um and you know if he's found guilty of
these charges he could even end up in
prison for decades
um but that doesn't officially count him
out of running for the presidency now
you might expect that a president
um you know charged with these crimes
very very serious crimes uh facing uh
trial facing a grand jury that that in
the court of public opinion might
prevent him from running for the
presidency again but the issue is of
course America is hugely divided his
very loyalist voters
um don't don't believe that you know
he's guilty of these these charges
obviously that's yet to be determined
and he is portraying this as a Witch
Hunt to his supporters now that's a
familiar refrain to us here in the UK
because Boris Johnson has also been
using that term in relation to the
privilege privileges committee report on
whether we must let Parliament which
we'll be talking about later but um yes
it's it's you know he says it's a a
Witch Hunt that these charges are jumped
up and there are lots of people in
America who believe that so incredible
though it may sound he may still yet end
up running for uh the presidency again
even with these charges hanging over him
and Henry uh Boris Johnson still
dominating many headlines as well he's
he's urging uh tonight uh the Privileges
committee to publish their report and
many of them are predicting uh quite how
damning they could be it could be for
him
yeah well I mean it's good of him to
urge them to publish it but if they were
going to publish it anyway uh and as far
as I'm aware they're going to publish it
tomorrow anyway but yes absolutely we
haven't seen the Privileges report yet
but we can infer a lot from it from the
way Boris Johnson has responded to it he
was given Advanced side of it on Friday
uh and he chose to resign from Palmer
which tells you I think an awful lot
about what it's going to say now the the
way this works is that effect
effectively the Privileges committee
which is a cross-party committee of MPS
which actually has a conservative
majority although it's chaired by a
labor MP have been investigating the
allegation of whether or not Boris
Johnson misled the House of Commons they
will recommend a sanction to the House
of Commons and the whole House of
Commons which again remember has a big
conservative majority has to vote on it
and if they vote to suspend him for more
than 10 days then he is subject to
what's called a recall petition a recall
petition means that uh 10 percent of the
voters in his constituency can sign a
petition to have a by-election now
that's important to understand because
essentially what what this is when he's
I like when he's allergic to witch
Hunters he is and when he's calling the
the committee a kangaroo court think
about what the logic of that actually is
it means that a committee which has a
conservative majority including a
long-standing brexiteer and Tori MP from
the red wall has has chosen to go for
Boris Johnson that they will make
recommendations which the House of
Commons which has a conservative
majority which he delivered not three
years ago will then vote for that then
the 10 of his constituents will choose
to have a recall a referendum a recall
petition and then that he would lose the
by-election yeah that's the allegation
that that chain of events is what
Johnson is claiming is a Witch Hunt
against him it's absurd I forget how
much she loved the detail Henry we're
gonna have to move on with a slightly
short of time Sonia just a brief thought
from you about the front page of the eye
um just so many people concerned about
their mortgages with interest rates set
to rise
yeah this is going to be a really
worrying front page for so many people
so uh interest rates are now forecast to
increase to
5.75 by the end of 2023 which means that
we'll see mortgage rates upwards of six
percent millions of people with fixed
rate mortgages uh ending in the next two
three months we're going to have to try
and re-fix at these new higher rates
that's going to add a huge amount on to
people's monthly repayments at a time
when the cost of living is going up food
and energy costs are higher so um I
think it's a really worrying time for
people yeah absolutely certainly a huge
concern for so many households Sonja
Henry thank you so much lots more to
talk about in the next hour we'll give
you a little bit of a break thanks very
much in